so I have a function here H of n and
let's say that it explicitly defines the
terms of a sequence so let me make a
little let me make a quick quick table
here so we have N and then we have H of
n when n is equal to 1 H of n is
negative 31 minus 7 times 1 minus 1
which is going to be this is just going
to be 0 so it's going to be negative 31
when n is equal to 2 it's going to be
negative 31 minus 7 times 2 minus 1 so 2
minus 1 well this is just going to be 1
so it's negative 31 minus 7 which is
equal to negative 38 when n is equal to
3 it's going to be negative 31 minus 7
times 3 minus 1 which is just 2 so we're
going to subtract 7 twice so it's going
to be negative 31 minus 14 which is
equal to negative 45 so what do we see
happening here well we're starting at
negative 31 and then we keep subtracting
we keep subtracting negative 7 we keep
subtracting negative 7 from that in fact
we subtract negative 7 1 less than the
term we subtract negative 7 1 less times
in the term we're dealing with if we're
dealing with the third term we subtract
negative 7 twice if we're dealing with
the second term we subtract negative 7
watts so this is all nice but what I
want you to do now is pause the video
and see if you can define this exact
same sequence so the sequence here is
you start at negative 31 and you keep
subtracting negative 7 so negative 38
negative 45 the next one is going to be
negative 52 and you go on and on and on
you keep subtracting negative 7 can we
define this this sequence in terms of a
recursive function so why don't you have
a go at that alright let's try to define
it in terms of a recursive function
let's just call that G of n so G of n
it's always a recursive function is
easier because you could say okay look
the first term when N is equal to 1 if n
is equal to 1 let me just write it if n
is equal to 1
if n is equal to one what's G of n going
to be it's going to be negative 31
negative 31 and if n if n is greater
than one and a whole number so this is
going to be defined for all positive
integers and whole and whole number well
it's going to be it's just going to be
the previous term so G of n minus one
minus seven minus seven so we're saying
if we get a if we if we if we're just
picking an arbitrary term we just have
to look at the previous term and then
subtract and then subtract seven it all
works out nice and nice and easy because
you keep looking at previous previous
previous terms all the way all the way
until you get to the base case which is
when n is equal to one and then you can
build up back from that and you get this
exact same sequence let's do another
example but or let's go the other way
around so here we have a we have a
sequence defined recursively and I
wanted to I want to create a function
that defines the sequence explicitly so
let's think about this so one way to
think about it this sequence when n is
equal to 1 it starts at nine point six
and then every term is the previous term
minus 0.1 so the second term is going to
be the previous term minus 0.1 so it's
going to be nine point five then going
to go to nine point four then you're
going to go to nine point three we could
keep going on and on and on or if we
want we can make a little table here and
we could say this is n this is H of N
and you see when n is equal to one H of
n is nine point six when n is equal to
two we're now in this case over here
it's going to be H of two minus one so
it's going to be H of one minus 0.1 well
it's just going to be this minus 0.1
which is going to be nine point five
when H is three it's going to be H of
two H of two minus 0.1 minus 0.1 well H
of two is right over here you subtract
1/10 you're going to get nine point four
exactly what we saw over here so let's
see if we can pause the video now
and define this create a function that
that constructs or defines this
arithmetic sequence explicitly here it
was recursively we wanted to find it
explicitly all right so let's just call
it I don't know let's just call it f of
N and we could say look it's going to be
nine point six but we're going to
subtract we're going to subtract zero
point one depending a certain number of
times depending on what term we're
talking about so we're going to subtract
zero point one but how many times are we
going to subtract it as a function of n
well let's see if we're going about the
first term we subtract zero times the
second term we subtract one time the
third term we subtract two times the
fourth term we subtract three times so
whatever term we're talking about we
subtract that term minus one times so if
we talk about the nth term we subtract n
might we subtracted this value n minus
one times and you can verify that this
is going to work when n is equal to one
this term here is going to be 0 so this
whole thing's going to be zero you get
nine point six when n is equal to two
two minus one
you subtract zero point one one time
nine point six minus zero point one is
nine point five and you could keep doing
that you could draw a table and evaluate
these if you want to but the key thing
is you're starting at nine point six and
you're subtracting zero point one one
fewer times then the term you're looking
at so if you're looking at the if n is
equal to this is n is equal to four well
you're going to subtract zero point one
three times and you see that subtract
zero point one once subtract zero point
one twice subtract zero point one three
times